Speaker 1: Let's talk about this continued
battle over documents about Donald Trump's
actions leading up to and during the January six,
2021, attempted insurrection, also known as the
Trump riots. Donald Trump is panicking about the
fact that documents may soon be released outlining
his activity on and leading up to January 6th.
Bess Levin has a great article in Vanity Fair
called Trump sounds pretty panicked about Congress
finding out exactly what he was up to on January
6th. Let's take a look at what she writes. And
you can find this article in the description for
today's YouTube clip. As you've no doubt heard
by now, Donald Trump is extremely unhappy about
the work being performed by the House Committee
investigating the Jan. six attack on the Capitol,
presumably because he knows that what they will
find will make him look even worse than he already
does, which is saying a lot, given he already
looks like a guy who tried to overthrow the
government because his parents never hugged him
as a child. Unfortunately for Trump, Joe Biden
thinks it's actually very important for Congress
to have access to the information it has requested
concerning the days surrounding the insurrection
and earlier this month rejected his predecessor's
claims of executive privilege over the documents
in question. Yes. Donald Trump, through lawyers,
has tried to assert executive privilege so that
these documents are not released. That has so
far been rejected. So now, instead of letting the
investigation unfold like an innocent person with
nothing to hide would, Trump is instead seek his
lawyers on the government. Per the New York Times.
Former President Trump sued Congress and the
National Archives Monday, seeking to block
the disclosure of White House files related to
his actions and communications surrounding the
Jan. six Capitol riot. This is a panic demand.
This is not how an innocent person behaves,
which has been a trend with Trump in a 26 page
complaint. A lawyer for Trump argued the materials
must remain secret as a matter of executive
privilege. He said the Constitution gives
Trump the right to demand their confidentiality,
even though he's no longer in office. And even
though Biden has refused to assert executive
privilege over them, the lawsuit touches off what
is likely to be a major legal battle between Trump
and the House Committee, etc. A best Levin goes on
to write in what is now basically boilerplate
language for Trump and his allies. His lawyer,
Jesse Binzel, claimed in the complaint that Biden
is simply sucking up to Liberal Democrats who want
to see Trump, a noted saint who's never done
anything wrong in his life, held accountable
in a political ploy to accommodate his
Partizan allies. Biden has refused to
assert executive privilege over numerous clearly
privileged documents requested by the committee.
Now we actually have a legal opinion about
this. In explaining why executive privilege
does not extend to a guy who tried to have the
results of a free and fair election overturned,
White House Attorney Dana Remus told the
National Archives quote The constitutional
protections of executive privilege should not
be used to shield from Congress or the public
information that reflects a clear and apparent
effort to subvert the Constitution itself.
What Trump was up to on January 6th would destroy
the very fabric of our constitutional separation
of powers, and therefore the documents should be
released. This includes schedules, calendars and
movement logs about virtual or in-person meetings
or events Trump attended and who was present.
Communication between the White House and
Trump allies pushing to overturn the election.
This stuff is a disaster for Trump. That includes
communication with Rudy Giuliani. Michael Flynn,
Roger Stone and Steve Bannon. White House
communications with Mike Lindell, known as Mike
Pillow, who spent the last year spreading baseless
conspiracies, et cetera, et cetera. Listen,
we know what Trump was doing in broad
strokes, right? The arc of Jan. six
vis-a-vis Trump's involvement was he encouraged
the insurrection during his speech in the morning,
gleefully watched it happen, refused to send
in the National Guard as things were getting
crazy and people were saying send in the
National Guard and then started to get
annoyed that the pro-Trump rioters looked
low, class and trashy. Those are his words.
And then he sort of did a video saying, Hey,
guys, go home. It was great. We love you.
You're great people. You're justified
in what you're doing, but go home.
That's basically what happened now. Filling in
would be how much planning took place in advance
about what was expected to take place. How much
did Trump knowingly coordinate with others to
try to make exactly this take place? Because the
big picture, the whole point of this thing was
delay the counting of the electoral votes
to somehow allow the Supreme Court intervene
and make Trump president for four more years
now. How the Supreme Court would have intervened,
how you would really, in a semi-permanent way,
delay the count of the vote. He had the idea.
Maybe Mike Pence would help, but Pence said, I
can't do that. I simply can't do that. A lot of
these details either are missing or just make no
sense whatsoever. That's all perfectly reasonable.
We know that. But the big picture is the arc I
just described for you. And having that filled in
with documents, communication memos, phone calls,
et cetera, would put beyond any doubt whatsoever
what was likely Trump's specific actions in order
to cause exactly what happened to have happened.
And that's why he's panicking, whether we will
ultimately publicly get these documents. We don't
know. Remember that a lot of this is about all of
this is about the release of these documents and
communications to the House Committee. Would they
leak if they got to the House committee? Maybe,
but we don't know whether they would actually
deliberately be made public, so that's not even
actually what this is about. But clearly Donald
Trump believes it's possible that they would. So
we'll see ultimately what happens with the
documents, Trump panicking, and rightly so because
of what what is publicly known points to what
is private right now is probably even crazier.